hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
livestream sort of podcast Q&A section
what this is is a video in which Heather
and I are going to speak into the camera
and record the answers to the questions
that you filed over super chat the
reason that we are not doing this live
is that we have experienced the most
bizarre and spectacular set of seemingly
unrelated technical glitches all in a
row it's hard to fathom we've had three
separate computers fail seemingly
independently and so we we had that many
computers in the room well there you go
now you do yeah as a stopgap measure we
have decided to take up drinking like
any adult would in this circumstance
Cheers alright I feel better already
mmm-hmm okay so we are going to address
I no longer have this up because your
questions
oh so keep talking for a minute while I
find this talk yeah speaking into the
camera and I'm saying things that are
you know here's the thing
I am wondering in light of the
spectacular set of technical glitches if
we should get out of the livestream
business all together and I should take
up Instagram modeling to substitute for
the income like whole body or hand model
or any particular thing gotten that far
was just kind of thinking it through
okay alright that's something to think
about for sure for sure for sure for
sure yes alright okay and I apologize
for that image to those of you watching
at home oh well I mean last time you put
in everyone's head the idea of Sam
Harrison a french maid outfit I did and
now it's um you as an Instagram model
awesome certain I think that's fine okay
fair enough it's fine for me okay so I
was actually going to start by
addressing a question that came in on
the last live streams Q&A about why
India and other Southeast Asian
countries have apparently such lower
rates of koban 19and infection by size
cope too then one would normally expect
so I'm gonna just start by reading you I
can find my list here a list of
possibilities that's been that was in
print sent to us by our friend Keiko
it's not it's just a newspaper article I
haven't found anything written in the
scientific literature about this but
here's a list of six possibilities that
I'm just gonna fly by you and let's see
let's talk a little bit about what you
think of each of them after I read all
of them great I suspect we will have
similar responses so why does India and
other Southeast Asian countries but
especially Linda Howe India have lower
than expected rates of CO mid-nineteen
warmer and more humid weather protection
offered by the old TB vaccine that's the
BCG vaccine which we've talked about
before here more people in India will
have had the BCG vaccine of all ages
then it's only people above a certain
age I don't even know what in the US
they would have had BCG potentially
better immune response among those in
the Indian subcontinent compared to
people say in Europe or the u.s. a
weaker strain of the virus in India more
effective and earlier physical
distancing relative to when Koba 19 was
first spreading through these countries
so this again raises this question of if
it didn't get to India until say late
March at the point that the rest of the
world had mostly figured out what was
going on India was in a much better
position to watch and to put in place
social distancing in lockdown measures
that looked like it was at the same time
as other countries but was in fact laid
earlier relative to when the infection
hit their country and then finally lower
testing numbers as compared to the rest
of the world which is both true but
seems by all accounts to be insufficient
so it is partially explanatory but not
wholly explanatory of the lower than
expected rates of co19
any reactions yeah well first of all
that list is are any of the mutually
exclusive I don't think so I don't think
so so we're looking for a set that
explains the discrepancy between the
numbers we see in the numbers that that
we expect and it's also not
not only a nun not only are none of
these mutually exclusive but I don't
think this is likely to be an exhaustive
list right I would say I'm doubtful
about the issue of warmer and more humid
I see that invoked periodically I've
heard it invoked over Florida but then
there's Guayaquil exactly yeah and why
Hill is remains a terrible situation and
suggests that at least if there is any
benefit to warmer and more humid that
it's really limited and to the degree
that we can control for geography as we
were trying to do in the first part of
this livestream like comparing Norway
and Sweden or Sweden and Denmark Quito
Quito Guayaquil being Ecuador's largest
cities key toes at altitude it's it's
close to eight 9,000 feet and glide
kills in the lowlands close to zero feet
in altitude Quito has a far less severe
situation on its hands than Guayaquil
and there may well be other factors but
certainly the warmer lowland climate of
Guayaquil seems to have been if anything
anti protective rather than protective
yeah I would say India is also
tremendously diverse in terms of its
climate sure certainly have as places
that match that description but anyway
it's easily tested because the variation
ought to give you a consistent pattern
if that's what's causing it I would say
in response to that though that well I
doubt that warmer and more humid as an
explanation it might be that that is a
proxy for people being outside yeah and
that being outside more may well be
protective and that also may be
explanatory with regard to Florida yeah
in fact I was speaking to our friend
Dave who's in Florida I was asking about
what I thought might be going on there
and I said that very same thing it may
be that it leads people to be outside
all right the TB vaccine this also seems
like it ought to be pretty easy to test
especially I think we've talked about it
on the podcast before that in places
where this old test or this old vaccine
was used there are certainly people
who've arrived more recently and haven't
had it and you have to be able to test
populations against each other and
figure out what fraction of the
pattern is accounted for exactly but I'm
basically favorable to the idea that
there's some interaction based on what
I've seen potentially better immune
response again easily tested I'm dubious
but it is not impossible yeah but but
why right like why why would we expect
people on the Indian subcontinent to
have a better immune response than
Germans or Americans or Japanese people
yeah I mean I guess I wonder a little
bit whether it stops at the border with
Pakistan yeah although you know the a
lot of the Southeast Asian countries and
I guess India South Asian but South
Asian and South Asian countries seem to
have a lower than expected rates okay um
let's see weaker strain of the virus
possible but doubtful would be very
hopeful of the answers on this list
maybe the best in the sense that it's
functioning in some sense as a vaccine
creating more he herd immunity with less
illness but if if if this weaker strain
whatever exactly that means having it
provided immunity against all the
strands yeah I find it doubtful but okay
more effective and earlier physical
distancing relative to when kovat
nineteen was first spreading for this is
likely that we're testing numbers as you
said is true but probably inadequate yep
yep all right okay so that's that's
where we're at on India let's go to your
C which are questions if in smaller font
and a slightly smaller font I'll try to
increase the size once we're done with
this one considering Brett's academic
interest in cultural evolution I you
with Dawkins could you discuss Co
Wilson's work and your opinions of his
positions on Concilium and his
controversial book the social conquest
of Earth why I do not know the social
conquest of Earth that must be a
relatively recent one I haven't even
heard of it I haven't read it I'm aware
of it let's say Wilson is a complex
figure he is one of the Great's when it
comes to ant biology he was
an early pioneer in sociobiology though
he is much resented for having gotten
credit because he published a book under
that name in my opinion late in his
career he has gone a little bit off the
rails in part because of a long-standing
resentment against against Bill Hamilton
who got credit for kin selection and
he's embraced group selection of which I
am NOT a fan I do believe there is a
resolution to the group selection versus
kin selection debate which has yet to be
explored fully and obviously nothing is
as we expected but David Sloan Wilson
and I were scheduled for a fall meeting
on stage somewhere
my guess is at this point we should do
it online instead so David if you're out
there let's consider that let's let's
hope that we are back interacting in
real life and in real time by the fall
I'll drink to that as well so I'm going
to jump around we will answer all the
questions this time because there aren't
that many of them and because you all
put up with so many technical problems
here so this one is sort of in keeping
with the last question while at academia
did you ever get caught up in the
clashes against evopsych against
adaptation ISM in humans by gold and
rose and I would say luetin on one side
versus EO Wilson Pinker Dawkins and the
others it's an interesting list of
characters
James SC has listed here and this this
could be the subject of an entire series
of podcasts anything you want to say
yeah in some sense this was the water we
swam in that the laboratory the Dick
Alexander laboratory that we were both
members of was very much at the heart of
this debate and I at Dick's memorial
service some months ago at a year ago at
this point a friend reminded me of an
incident that I had completely forgotten
where Stephen Jay Gould had
come to lecture at Michigan and I had
thoroughly embarrassed him I did
something that I sort of became known
for I figured out what the devastating
question to ask was and I delivered it
to him it was cool not luangta slow
anton came to linton came to and there
was a whole different episode with
bloomington um but no it was Gould in
this case I had forgotten the whole
thing um but in any case yeah it was fun
it's one of your strengths right is
listening and waiting and figuring out
exactly the right incisive question so
as to be simultaneously respectful and
pointed well I mean the thing is there's
a question that needs to be asked and
what happens is either the person on the
other end understands the question and
deals with it head-on and has a good
answer which you know just so delightful
it's exactly what everyone wants yep or
or they fumble and reveal that they were
hiding something that they knew was a
weakness in their argument etc so anyway
yeah it's um it's very important stuff I
will say I don't think either side had
it right we we are we come from the
lineage of kin selection s but I am
persuaded that the kin selection is
actually had an error that they were
doing the logic right but they didn't
extrapolate from it far enough and that
much that we trip over now is the result
of the fact that they see that they've
got the logic right but they don't
understand that that doesn't mean that
they missed the extrapolation so anyway
exactly some of what you were hoping to
talk about what Davidson Wilson on stage
but I would also say the question also
asks sort of it at a less granular level
what about clashes against adaptation
ISM and humans which could be read as
the kind of stuff that we saw firsthand
in our undergraduate experience working
with Bob Trevor's one of the other great
you know perhaps the greatest living
evolutionary biologist and he was
constantly battling and we would hear
about these battles with the people
including some of the people we
ourselves were taking classes from who
didn't actually believe that you should
be talking about things like sexual
selection or reciprocal altruism
or female choice remember competition
when it came to humans even primates in
some cases and so it's really
extraordinary that in the set up in the
early 90s you had people teaching
biological anthropology and other sort
of you know the the evolutionary
underpinnings of what it is to be human
who were saying things like we shall not
discuss sexual selection yeah and in
fact now that I look at it because EO
Wilson has come late to the group
selection side I'm actually
misunderstanding the question that's
really being asked which is more in the
realm that you just described where a
backlash against adaptation ISM in
humans resulted in this this creation of
factions and you're right Lou Anton's
absence from the list is conspicuous and
a problem because Lou inton the famous
geneticist was a major player in
disrupting the understanding of how
human evolution works yeah with his and
gold's paper the spandrels of st. mark
the spandrels of 782 eighty-three thing
yes and now that you raised the issue of
that paper i realized that i made a
little video about the spandrels of san
marco conversions when we were in Italy
and I should rent for that footage up
and I should put the video out oh you
should yeah
for one thing Venice may be underwater
at this point right you may never travel
again the room is making me cough okay
Ecco asks if not in contact with another
human or animals emanations can we catch
a virus by being exposed to cold weather
only do we host latent viruses waiting
for cold weather immunities slowmode to
replicate no and yes you cannot the
viruses don't come out of nowhere you
have to contact a particle which like
everything else will have come from
ancestors however you can pick up a
particle of certain kinds and have it
wait for a moment that is advantageous
to it by some program that it has
inherited so what is the evolutionary
purpose of female clitorises having
migrated outside the vagina does it
enable bigger grip cohesion is
interference sexual play always present
in species where it occurs we can rely
on echo to always pack a lot of
questions into a single question
yeah very efficient in that case echo I
assume echo is man I guess I don't know
has introduced the concept of migrating
clitoris which is quite an image frankly
yeah it's one of the best ones to be
introduced on this in this podcast in
this [ __ ] yep it's a high on the list at
this point so alright I don't know you
know that that suggests that clitoris
position relative vagina was ever
anywhere else
and given the homology between female
and male I don't know why we should
expect that it was ever internal and
certainly in other you know other
mammals it's always where it is relative
to the two structures are where they are
relative to one another I don't think
anyone has ever asked where a lizard
clitoris is or if they have the no they
can't actually so PI can so the origin
is in mammals so there's there's the
lizards don't have they have a different
origin of penises and they don't have
vaginas birds have something else
entirely just of Chloe cos mammals have
the origin of penises and vaginas and so
it's always just where it is I don't
think they're migrating yeah what's the
situation in hyenas heavily modified
external male like male like even
mmm-hmm like hard to distinguish males
from females if you don't know exactly
what you're looking for if you're not a
hyena sexual dimorphism expert very
enlarged female clitoris is in spotted
hyenas look like penises not so much on
the other species of hyenas but
specifically in its creek utakata
spotted hyenas which have a strong
degree of sex role reversal yep alright
so anyway we fumbled around the question
we fumbled around the clitoris
yeah so anyway yeah I don't think it's a
very good answer I would be inclined to
look a couple things up and possibly
return to this question I think there's
a lot to be known that I don't know off
the top of my head about what it means
for other mammals to have a clitoris
because obviously most mammals don't
have sex for pleasure as far as we can
tell if you do and so there's a question
about what the structure is there might
be something that's home all I guess but
not functioning the same way well I bet
banishing vanishingly little isn't known
given that it was you know very recently
before most medical and scientific
professionals acknowledged that it was
real and that female orgasm was real I
have acknowledged this from the
beginning I know you okay uh-huh
but the idea that anyone is out there
looking for this in other mammal species
when it wasn't even believed to be real
universally in humans yeah really
unlikely yes bonobos would be a good
first choice to go looking to go yes
they would almost certainly have they
didn't fight you and bonobo
professionals would be early in the
acknowledgement I would imagine yeah
yeah but in other species their version
of patriarchy might be suppressing the
information we should look at lemurs who
suffer from no patriarchy at all right a
male dominance and lemurs we should yeah
we should see what they have written
about it good yeah all right okay
yeah the room is beginning to manifest
my 12 year old seeing this power boy oh
wow I'm gonna take back everything we
just said I'm gonna move this little a a
little bit later so it's not quite such
a such a counterpoint yeah do you think
that hybridization between species is a
big contributor to genetic diversity I
have often wondered about this never
heard it discussed but I'm not a
biologist loved the podcasts thank you
um I got a response to you all right so
here's the thing hybrids happen a lot
more than we think they don't always do
well sometimes they do really well and
there's a question about what we even
mean so in other words if you take a
cladogram that involves a lot of forks
we
sort of the Assumption cladogram being
an evolutionary tree an evolutionary
tree and you zoom in you will find that
at some level what you really have is a
net you don't have bifurcations are
those hybridization events well no you
know if you you know become fond of some
person you know three towns over and you
mate across some line that's larger than
the usual distance it's not a
hybridization event and the thing that
haunts your question is that we do not
have a good definition for species so I
would say we have this funny little
predicament I've become enamored of the
idea I think I'm the inventor of the
idea speciation is a good concept
species is a bad concept another one
would be genetic is a good concept gene
is a bad concept so these are places
where something happens we have a
process that takes something that was
once clearly not to species and
eventually turns it into something that
clearly is to species but in between
there's a lot of gray and all kinds of
things occur so what I would suggest is
hybridization happens at levels that are
so low we don't call it hybridization
and so late that we you know look at it
and say that's just an anomaly like
ligers you can make a liger but lions
and tigers don't encounter each other in
the wild so it's obviously just a
curiosity but we have every other
version of this so so I mean it raises
it raises questions that we could speak
for an entire academic quarter semester
about at some level and you know the
main one being what is a species and let
therefore the lines between them but one
one thing that you didn't raise I think
is that this is going to be really
different in different clades so
vertebrates so what happens when you
have an evolutionary tree branching and
then occasionally some of those branches
come back together to meet one another
it's called reticulation the
reticulation event and you see a lot
less reticulation coming back together
hybridization if you will in vertebrates
then you do even in vertebrates and
certainly than in plants or mushrooms
are single-celled organisms either with
nuclei or not so you have all sorts of
reticulation events over in plant space
all sorts of hybridization events and
there are some clear unknown biological
reasons for this things like plants
don't have what's called a segregated
germline they don't have separation of
the basically the sexual line from the
non-sexual or somatic line the soma
which also affects the way they stand
nests for people who are following that
thread of the conversation yep yep and
there and there are a number of other
biological reasons why you would expect
reticulation or hybridization loosely
synonymous terms reticulation and
hybridization to be more common in
plants than they aren't animals for
instance and vertebrates it being
extraordinarily rare at this level that
we like to think of speciation happening
is true but then there's also this truth
that it's happening all the time at this
really close up really short time skill
level and not at all between you know
rhinoceroses and that's not just because
the size difference but there's some
sort of intermediate level of genetic
distance where things could happen it
could work but it's unlikely to for any
number of reasons most of the time so I
would also point out that this plays
into the discussion that we have had in
a couple places including on Joe Rogan
about the different level of enthusiasm
for casual sex as between males and
females so this is about the
rhinoceroses in the bats no okay no in
that case I think it's a bit of a
stretch but but from the point of view
in species in which males invest nothing
in offspring their willingness to
hybridize will be greater because they
have less to lose in other words if they
fertilize a female from a different
species and that tends and it ends up
being a negative from the point of view
of the offspring they haven't lost very
much from the females perspective they
will have lost a great deal but the
final thing to have in this piece of
conversation is that there is a very
interesting phenomenon called hybrid
vigor
now hybrid vigor is especially visible
where we have things like purebred
strain
purebred strange that's human beings
pure breeding something and then taking
two pure breads and combining them and
finding that the combination actually
has extraordinary capacities now in part
this will be because the breeding of a
purebred line will result in really bad
compromise so they're yeah they're
effectively it's very much akin to
immune suppression we're all walking
around being immune suppressants let's
boost our immune system actually let's
let's get it back to baseline yep right
but so in this case human breeding you
will maximize some character at the cost
of a lot of other things and then if you
combine two things in which we've
maximized different characters you'll
regain some of the value that you lost
the final thing I will say is that when
I was actively working on bats this is a
subject we should come back to but when
I was actively working on bats it was
surprising how often I would end up with
a bat in the hand that did not fall out
as one or the other that hovered between
two known species and the conclusion not
just mine but also Charles Handley who
was a curator of mammals at the
Smithsonian and one of my mentors he
concluded that many of these were in
fact hybrids and the the idea is that
the hybridization happens more than we
think but because it doesn't tend to
stick we don't know about it so anyway
there's a lot to your question it's a
good one yeah and so this is a little
bit related maybe to some of how you
just answered Brett another one from
echo study on mosquitoes studies on
mosquitoes show positive genetic
correlation between male genital lengths
and female brain size possibly linked to
increased female cognitive ability to
avoid male coercion it's not politically
correct can you discuss so I mean it
sounds like the possible hypothesis that
echo was alluding to is that this is
sort of an arms race that as male
genital length increases female brain
size increases in order to avoid
coercive reproductive events and and you
have a arms race I don't that's
certainly only one of many possible
explanations and I don't I'd love to see
what the study is to see if this is
actually true
I'm just struggling with the idea that
mosquito cognitive ability is somehow
important you know I would I'm
struggling at the idea of male gentle
lengthen the mosquito frankly all right
I'm gonna try not to take that
personally in the mosquito I don't know
you're struggling with the concept of
male genital length they don't miss keep
all right um have you seen any research
or data around the efficacy of vitamins
C and D and preventing treating SARS
Gove - a little haven't delved into it
enough but I see people talking about
vitamin D as a promising thing I have no
idea with whether this stands up to
scrutiny or not yet it's on my list of
things to look into but um I will say
that things that we have thought were
promising have turned out not to be and
some of them are counterproductive
maybe vitamin D is gonna go this way but
see yeah we do have this anomalous and
seemingly very important fact about
outdoors
that's certainly consistent with vitamin
D being important that's right and at
this point because this is so
fast-moving and we have you know
incomplete and often flawed data coming
in it's really hard to understand the
distinction but you know as the question
actually is explicit about it asks about
preventing and treating and there will
be some drugs which will be effective in
one and not the other all right and we
know this from malaria for instance we
know this from all sorts of things so
it's quite possible that getting enough
vitamin C or let's let's call it vitamin
D that's getting enough vitamin D is
preventative against getting it but once
you get it no amount of vitamin D is
going to help you in the course of the
disease yeah making that up I don't know
if that's true but it's it's quite
possible that something would be
effective somewhat effective in
preventing you're getting it but then
not effective in treating it once you
got it I think I also recall that iron
is one of these things that an iron
deficiency makes you vulnerable so
having enough iron makes you resistant
to various things but during certain
infections iron levels in the blood
crash and it's probably an adaptation
where the body is denying iron
the tunes that utilize it yeah and this
could actually be relevant to SARS co2
as we talked about in early livestreams
there seems to be a connection with
hemoglobin absolutely my 12 year old is
seeing this podcast the first time says
this is boring by the second time she
was laughing at Brett's jokes in the Q&A
now she's a fan
thanks for the podcast this is from Eric
Knight who asks if we can give a
shout-out to J and Casey absolutely J
the 12 year old fan we are honored Casey
I think is Kansas City yeah I'm just a
fan uh he also likes my jokes
I think this kid's gonna be okay you
think so yeah I do I will say that when
I think of Kansas City I think of my
time there when I was about 12 visiting
an aunt and uncle and cousins and going
waterskiing there so I actually have fun
memories of Kansas City thank you for
that last time you implied that
recombination of viruses is rare and
that this is evidence of it being a lab
maid but isn't this how we have new flu
strains also couldn't recombination
occur in a third animal recombination of
viruses is not rare flu in particular
has a known mechanism for this in which
different components are exchanged I
know the part of the last live stream
you're talking about in which I said
that I do not mean to imply that it's
rare but what I'm what I did mean to
imply was that the particular
hybridization event would require these
two strains which were in very different
creatures to have found themselves in
the same cell of a particular creature
not saying it couldn't happen in fact
what I really want is for a wide open
discussion to occur in which we consult
the people who know pangolins the people
who know rhino loaf and bats and we find
out whether the ecology provides any
situation in which this might normally
occur
my guess is to the extent that those
experts exist they would know a lot
about the ecology that could tell us
what to make of the fact that we've got
a spike protein seeming to come from a
Pangolin and the rest of the genome
seeming to come from a rhino loaf at bat
maybe it means nothing maybe it means
something but I do not mean to imply
that viruses do not find ways to
recombine
but coronaviruses are not like flu virus
there seems to be a huge huge mismatch
between the severity of the corona
pandemic and the social cost imposed by
lockdown those who protest the trakone
ian's measures are stigmatized despite
the obvious cost so there's no question
there you know we have a somewhat
different position that the severity is
a mismatch for the lockdown and of
course a successful lockdown is
successful and necessary lockdown will
inherently look like it was somewhat
unnecessary and there's really very
little way to tell the difference unless
you have well controlled situations in
the world where some locked down and
some didn't and we talked a little bit
about this in the first part of this
live stream where Norway was at Norway
versus Sweden Norway did lockdown and
has an order of magnitude close to fewer
deaths than Sweden which didn't do
lockdown but you know it's you're
talking about the severity and stigma I
think we've beginning to get stigma on
both sides frankly I think this is
becoming an almost explicitly political
problem and it's that's diabolical it's
not that's not the way they should have
gone and yet of course it's going that
way yeah it's a it's a disaster frankly
we are all in this together and at the
moment we're all in it together at the
same level of lockdown more or less at
least within the US and the relaxation
of the lockdown is going to put us at
odds with each other in a very dangerous
way but we shouldn't be stigmatizing
people as we said in the first half of
this the discussion has to be had out in
the open yeah oh one more thing I wanted
to say on that before you conclude that
this was an overreaction you need to
look at places like parts of Italy New
York City Guayaquil and the question is
those places where it feels like an
overreaction did we avoid that yeah if
you can avoid being Guayaquil or New
York City or parts of Italy it was worth
it
and the danger that what we don't know
about this virus has left us all
vulnerable to finding ourselves in such
a situation is very great yeah Chris
Thompson writes these streams is such a
pleasure many thanks from Shetland thank
you thanks Chris is a scientific
American compromised who can lay people
trust for science info Matt writes and
he has a link to a scientific American
blog which is proclaiming that fat is
not the problem fat stigma is this
sounds like exactly the same style of
article that I was talking about a few
livestreams ago that came out of Wired
yes Scientific American is compromised
now this is one of their blogs and
they've they've gone off the rails and
their blogs for a few years now there
was there was some stuff few couple one
or two years ago about the non reality
of male and female and you know that's
obviously an appalling position for a
so-called scientific journal for the
layperson to be taking who can lay
people trust unfortunately it's about
figuring out how to do first principles
thinking and from there looking for the
people who you think are making sense
checking their logic constantly
constantly constantly and then at some
point some people I hope we for instance
will start to earn your trust
legitimately enough that you don't have
to fact-check
or logic check every single thing that
we say but you kind of have to do it
from first principles with every new
person and source that comes into your
into your feed yeah trust networks may
be the answer yeah actually that's
that's right yep
Craig writes I understood your point
regarding the lesser of two evils but oh
so do you also support ranked choice
voting
rcv and nonpartisan blanket primaries
and BBP ranked choice voting yes
nonpartisan blanket primaries probably I
must say I'm so dismayed at the two
parties that we've got that one needs to
step beyond that in order to figure out
in a normal University our T's would you
want
primary's within party and all of that
but at the moment what we've got is two
parties that have fallen over under
closely related spells and we either
have to free them which is seeming very
unlikely or replace them which i think
is more possible than others do but but
yes in general solutions that alter the
voting landscape to restore the
democratic force it makes good sense
okay I'm gonna ask the next question
have you begin to answer it then I'm
gonna get up and let the cat in because
he's yelling all right do you have any
insight into the possible adaptive
function of panic attacks and run away
anxiety responses or anxiety disorders
in general yeah I believe that I do and
what I would point out is that and
there's more to come on this topic soon
but your dream architecture involves
analogs of these things and the question
of whether they find themselves out of
place during your waking life is I think
important more on that later but yes I
do believe what you're looking at is a
case of something that is adaptive in a
different context showing up in a place
where it is maladaptive that appears to
be a cat hello have you heard of kovat
syndrome yet actually it's written sort
of in pirate EES have you heard of Co
bird syndrome yet have ye heard of yeah
I haven't I have not either thanks to
both of you appreciate the rationale
voices Thank You cat okay this next one
is written not entirely in English and I
don't know really what it means hmm I'm
going to try to read it Bret but um I'm
not sure - one shouldn't we have better
anti RESP tract cancer adaptation
adaptations okay breathing fire smoke
for half some number ten to the six
years
to also please talk to Peter TIA or
Sinclair David Sinclair David Sinclair
okay on any podcast okay so the second
part is just talked to Peter Tia who's
got an excellent podcast I don't know
David Sinclair yeah do you understand
the question enough to rephrase it I
think okay and I must say I you know
I've heard I think he may be sam harris
who has a riff from a number of years
ago on the dangers of fireplaces being
equivalent to smoking cigarettes yes
that's right actually yeah and i I
believe him but I must say I had the
same question which is human beings have
an awful long history of affiliation
with fire close affiliation towards
those tend to be outside they do tend to
be outside so I don't know the answer of
the question it's certainly worth
addressing it could be that differences
in type of would matter a great deal
that things for which we have ancestral
preparedness would be superior but I
don't know it's certainly a question all
right are the computers malfunctioning
the cats are mal fundamental the cats
were being fed by one of the children
and the cat who was locked in here with
us was not interested in hanging out
with us if he could have food I see yes
okay I understand that neither the
Bakersfield doctors are MDS but are
osteopath I was shocked when I read this
I looked it up we cannot show you what I
found because our tech support has a
phantom ship has left the building he's
left the building but it's not true
they are both they are both MDS I will
say too that this seems that struck me
is super surprising because my
admittedly limited and anecdotal
experience with MDS and dio's osteopath
is that osteopaths in general seem much
more likely to adhere to
a scientific approach to problem-solving
to Diagnostics to thinking through what
all the possible variables are that are
feeding in and to be much less likely to
be conclusion driven than they are
hypothesis driven so if these guys a
couple of Osteopathy had created that
video that would be shocking to me and
it turns out it's not true in this case
all right might a better name than
motivated reasoning be used to denote
evasion of that logical process in favor
of a chosen conclusion I don't know
motivated reasoning works for me I think
it it contains exactly the allegation
yeah inside the the term but if you've
got a better term offer it for sure yep
I feel like we already talked about
Wilson's work and cultural evolution oh
is this a slightly different question
well the earlier so I was the same no
it's the same I think it probably came
in on a different stream justice so it
does ask about Concilium sand I will
just say in general Concilium is kind of
a cool idea I believe it is implicit
really in the scientific approach in
other words science proceeds from the
belief that all of these things
ultimately distill down to some story
that works across all scales so maybe
it's not as radical as it sounds should
the humanities take a scientific
approach of course they should Guns
Germs and Steel is an excellent
demonstration that history needs a
scientific approach to be done properly
so anyway basically at the level of
Concilium stew the extent that I at
least understand it I would say
cautiously in favor of roughly that
approach absolutely
so we've got three more questions and a
couple of comments which I don't think
need to be said out loud here but we
said that we would read everything so
let me just start with those a test
someone said super chat was giving
errors apparently it wasn't and set
encoded to broadcast key frames every
two seconds that looks like some tech
advice we have received some supremacy
tech advice so thank you for that
okay last three questions if I'm banned
from normal chap for lowbrow trolling
can I still super shet apparently you
can this is the test this is that
hypothesis alright so what are the type
1 and type 2 error values for the tests
okay so this is gonna be a question
about false positives and false
negatives they vary they vary quite a
lot I actually haven't I have not heard
the numbers for the antigen test for the
so-called molecular tests the PCR test
those are all synonyms antigen molecular
PCR tests those aren't synonyms in any
other realm but in this case they are I
have not heard the numbers for false
positives and false negatives for those
I've been we've been more focused on the
serology tests which are the antibody
tests and they are ranging in the 95 to
99 percent for both false positives and
false negatives but they have very
different specifics depending on the
particular test and I don't think I have
much more to say beyond that final
question what is the adaptive advantage
of using language copying information
from speakers to listeners or speakers
benefit by influencing listening
behavior or listener behavior excuse me
well I would say this is the perfect
place to invite you to our Princeton
talk tomorrow where we will talk about
closely related issues that are involved
in consciousness and culture both of
which take advantage of language in an
extreme way and I can say that we
believe the answer we will deliver
tomorrow will be one you haven't heard
and will be hopefully fully satisfying
so that will be on April 29th at 4:30
p.m. Eastern for those who haven't heard
us talk about it before but if you're if
you're seeing this not within the first
24 hours of posting it it will be posted
by Princeton sometime after the
livestream the zoom webinar so it will
be available for you to go see and then
we will also be talking about this a bit
not so much focusing on language but a
bit the model of culture and
consciousness in the book under
gatherers guide to the 21st century and
which will be out and about
year assuming that the entire world does
not continue to go off the rails uh-huh
it's a big assumption it is a big
assembly yeah I wouldn't make that
assumption at this point all right to
the entire world not continuing to go
off the rails
all right there it is signing off